supongamos que tú estás desesperado por
dinero y que yo tengo un montón de
dinero para prestarle a otras personas
este soy yo
esta es mi cadena de oro entonces viene
si me dices oye sabes que es al la
verdad tengo urgencia de así de un
montón de dinero porque me voy a hacer
un trasplante de corazón y entonces
necesito diez mil pesos entonces
necesitas diez mil pesos
ahora yo tengo sus diez mil pesos y te
digo claro estoy dispuesto a prestar te
los pero como el economista difícil y
pues nunca sabes dónde cae tu dinero y
bueno realmente no sé si puedas mantener
tu trabajo después de la cirugía de
corazón y todo eso como yo soy muy
cuidadoso con mi dinero pues lo pensamos
tantito y decimos bueno sabes que este
reloj que traes en tu muñeca
ss bien padre y tú me dices este reloj
si se deja dibujo el reloj
este reloj y yo te digo si ese reloj y
tú me dices a veces que se me tratara
tátara tatarabuelo y vale pues no sé a
lo mejor es un rolex con un montón de
diamantes y vale no sé digamos treinta
mil pesos
y claro que yo sé eso porque como soy
rico ya me acostumbré al oro y a los
diamantes ya esas cosas caras entonces
te digo a ver yo confío en ti y tú
también confías en ti mira te voy a
prestar los diez mil pesos pero bueno
nada más para que sepamos que todas las
cosas van a marchar bien porque no me
dejas tu reloj de tu tátara tatarabuelo
y luego cuando me pagues los 10.000 con
además no sé un interés bajo de digamos
10 por ciento a la semana 10% a la
semana
la semana cuando me pagues el préstamo o
sea la cantidad inicial con su interés
correspondiente por el tiempo que
quieras te regreso tu reloj y tú me
dices pues no sé es que 10% suena como
un montón y yo te digo cómo crees nada
más lo necesitas para tu cirugía
entonces después trabajas unas cuantas
semanas y me pagas de regreso no es tan
malo pero ya
de hecho se compone como un interés
horrible pero tú estás desesperado
necesitas tu corazón entonces te digo
mira tú me vas a pagar verdad entonces
pues cuando me pagues vas a obtener tu
reloj de 30 mil de regreso entonces por
qué no simplemente me dejas este reloj
en garantía entonces te convenzo y dices
bueno va porque tienes tu trasplante de
corazón trabajas un montón pero es tan
difícil pagarme que nunca puedes
alcanzar a pagarme y me quedo con tu
reloj básicamente este es el sistema con
el cual funcionan los empeños sea tú
necesitas un préstamo dejas algo como
empeño y pues para no decirlo así estar
tan en bruto lo que dejas es una
garantía para el préstamo yo me atrevo a
hacerte el préstamo porque sé que si no
me puedes pagar entonces yo me quedo con
este bonito activo bueno esto es algo
que sucede todo el tiempo en partes
menos oscuras de nuestra economía por
ejemplo un banco te va a ser un préstamo
hipotecario pero lo va a garantizar con
la casa si no puedes pagar el préstamo
se van a quedar con la casa y bueno
incluso aunque la casa se devalúa un
poco pues pueden recuperar casi todo
estoy aquí fue un préstamo con garantía
súper directo me das una garantía yo te
doy el préstamo me pagas de regreso y te
regreso la garantía
ahora qué sucedería en una realidad en
la cual a mí como prestamista no me
gusta para nada este concepto de
garantía y todo eso más bien lo que a mí
me gustaría dejar super claro que soy
propietario del objeto en garantía
mientras yo lo tenga o sea no quiero que
de repente se aparezcan unos policías en
mi casa y me digan eide quien es esto de
quién es este reloj donde está el recibo
nos robaste o que está todo como muy
oscuro el reloj no me lo robe pero la
verdad para evitar incomodidades pues me
gustaría poder comprobar de alguna forma
que soy dueño del reloj en caso de que
no vengas a pagarme mi préstamo de
regreso va entonces en vez de esto vamos
a hacer la misma transacción otra vez
aquí estás tú por aquí estoy yo deja le
pongo sombrero y bigote esas son mis
características particulares y también
la cadena de oro ahora lo que podemos
hacer como yo quiero ser dueño del reloj
lo que podemos hacer es que yo te compre
ese reloj entonces me das el reloj en lo
que literalmente va a cambiar de manos
entonces te voy a comprar el reloj por
diez mil pesos
se lo compró en diez mil pesos y
entonces tú me das el reloj
y a cambio obtienes el dinero pero
aparte tenemos un trato por separado
mira hasta ahorita todo va casi igual
sin embargo la única diferencia es que
ahorita realmente estoy vendiendo el
dinero lo estoy vendiendo al comprarte
reloj gatti en realidad esta es una
transacción de efectivo estrictamente no
es un préstamo pero pues exactamente lo
mismo está pasando verdad acá arriba tú
me diste el dinero y yo te di 10 mil
pesos acá tú me diste el reloj y yo
también te di 10 mil pesos bueno lo que
hace esta cosa diferente es que además
vamos a hacer un trato por separado mira
esto de aquí es ahorita
este es ahorita entonces también vamos a
hacer un trato hace un trato por
separado de que en algún futuro en algún
futuro yo voy a querer venderte reloj y
tú vas a querer comprarlo de regreso
claro por un poco más de diez mil pesos
entonces en el futuro tú me vas a dar de
regreso mi dinero entonces van a ser
diez mil pesos 10 mil pesos más algo y
ese algo pues esencialmente es el
interés ok entonces yo voy a obtener mi
dinero de vuelta y luego te regresó el
reloj
ahora si lo piensas tantito esto es
económicamente idéntico a lo que hicimos
acá arriba
sí verdad yo te di 10 mil pesos tú
dejaste tu reloj en garantía y cuando me
pagas de vuelta con todo de intereses yo
te devuelvo tu reloj todo igualito sin
embargo allá arriba yo nunca fui el
dueño ilegítimo del reloj mientras que
acá abajo yo soy el dueño bueno pasa lo
mismo
vienes conmigo yo te hago un préstamo tú
me das el reloj pero fue porque yo te lo
compre entonces obtengo un recibo con
este recibo ya soy el dueño oficial del
reloj claro mientras tenga tu dinero
pero aparte tenemos un trato por
separado pero además tenemos un trato de
que en el futuro me vas a volver a
comprar el reloj este de aquí es el
reloj lo vas a volver a comprar por diez
mil pesos más una cantidad que
esencialmente es el interés entonces
este es un préstamo donde hay un reloj
en garantía pero la única diferencia es
que ahorita realmente me ven diste el
reloj y no sólo eso sino que también
tuvimos un contrato de recompra ya me
tardé seis minutos en decirlo pero creo
que valió la pena tenemos un contrato de
recompra
contrato de recompra en el cual tú estás
de acuerdo en que me vas a comprar el
reloj en algún momento de hecho yo soy
el dueño del contrato de recompra en la
transacción el prestamista o sea yo
obtiene un reloj y además un contrato de
recompra me voy a poner repo porque así
se conoce mucho por el inglés va
entonces yo me quedo con dos activos el
reloj y el contrato de recompra a cambio
tú obtienes el dinero y un contrato de
recompra inverso contrato de recompra
inverso bueno el chiste de todo esto es
que este contrato de recompra te obliga
a volver a comprar mi reloj en algún
momento por la cantidad inicial más algo
adicional que podemos pensarlo como el
interés por otro lado este contrato
inverso me obliga a mí a venderlo
prácticamente estamos haciendo un
contrato formado a largo plazo estamos
acordando que en el futuro haremos una
transacción a cierto precio ahora hice
todo esto porque esencialmente así es
como presta el banco de la reserva
federal especialmente en la ventanilla
de descuento pero antes de eso entonces
se conoce como
contrato de recompra o como una
transacción red
entonces lo que hace el banco federal
cuando alguien llega a la ventanilla de
descuento creo que ya es hora de que
dibuje hojas de balance bien supongamos
que este banco necesita dinero ahorita
no me voy a preocupar mucho por el lado
derecho de la hoja de balance tiene
cierto pasivo y cierto capital y
supongamos que también tiene un montón
de activos muchos activos supongamos que
estos son pagarés federales
sin embargo no tiene nada de efectivo
este es el banco que no tiene nada de
efectivo y por otro lado tenemos el
banco federal el banco de la reserva
federal deja veo sí puedo dibujar su
hoja de balance en limpio
el banco de la reserva mira casi todos
estos de aquí por el momento van a ser
pagarés federales por aquí está el
pasivo ahorita no me meto mucho con eso
y un poco de capital ahora supongamos
que tú eres uno de estos bancos parias
que nadie te quiere prestar y todo el
mundo empieza a sacar su dinero entonces
necesitas convertir estos pagarés en
efectivo y no quiere simplemente
tirarlos en el mercado a lo mejor tus
activos no son tan líquidos y si nada
más los tiras ahí no te van a pagar lo
que vale entonces esencialmente tienes
que hacer un contrato de recompra con el
banco federal triste es el banco federal
el banco de la reserva y vas con ellos
vas a la ventanilla de descuento y no sé
supongamos que la tasa de descuento está
en 5% ahorita no me quiero meter mucho
en eso y les dices el banco federal
préstame dinero entonces el banco
federal y se va a dejar imprimir los
billetes osea acaso no estás pendientes
y con eso pueden imprimir billetes
pero en vez de simplemente hacerte un
préstamo y quedarse con estos pagarés en
garantía lo que va a ser el banco
federal es comprarte o bueno entrar en
un contrato de recompra contigo vamos a
ver otra vez la mecánica entonces te
compra estos pagarés con esto los
pagarés a ver déjame ver si puedo
hacerlo voy a poner copiar y pegar sabes
que mejor copio y pego esto de acá
control
control b
entonces las notas de la reserva federal
los billetes van a ir de la reserva
federal de la reserva federal a ti y
luego tus pagarés sus pagarés van a ir
al banco de la reserva federal este es
efectivo efectivo que imprimió el banco
de la reserva federal con el cual
esencialmente pues te compro tus pagarés
estos pagarés
estos son los pagarés que antes estaban
por acá pero además hay un contrato de
recompra en el cual tú estás de acuerdo
que en algún futuro vas a deshacer esta
transacción o sea que vas a volver a
comprar tus pagarés y que vas a pagar la
cantidad que el banco federal que el
banco federal te prestó pero además con
cierto interés para entonces la forma
básica de verlo es que esto fue
simplemente un préstamo
simplemente tomaste prestado cierto
tanto del banco de la reserva el banco
de la reserva se quedó con tus pagarés
en garantía pero si era propietario
legítimo de ellos en ese tiempo eso es
justo lo que diferencia un contrato de
recompra de un contrato tradicional de
préstamo con garantía sin embargo además
te estás comprometiendo a volver a
comprar esos pagarés en algún futuro por
la cantidad que el banco de la reserva
te pagó inicialmente pero además con
cierto interés establecido por la tasa
de descuento en fin tema como el tiempo
pero en el siguiente vídeo veremos una
hoja de balance real del banco federal
de eeuu